[Music]
not fired on the isle of bute in
scotland there's been little to disturb
the ancient stretch of water in 10,000
years that's about to change
[Music]
200 miles from Butte in a workshop on
Tyneside
a new life is about to begin for
Bluebird k7 a team of volunteers have
spent best part of 20 years recovering
the Hydra planes wreckage and putting
her back together piece by piece all
ready to go then Johnny in the back ok
straight back I'll tell you what he in
turn she is precious cargo and they
don't want so much as a scratch on her
paintwork Johnny was scared his name it
blue birds life was once considered to
be well and truly over these engineers
divers and mechanics have taken her back
from grave to cradle but the jet boat
seems to be listing and nobody knows why
including project leader Bill Smith tell
it's a mother like me why it's at an
angle
at this stage bill and his team simply
can't afford any mistakes so there's
tension but also excitement
my all things fun it's all adventure you
know and you yeah the challenges and the
adventures get bigger and better
tomorrow Bluebird will set off on one of
the biggest adventures of her life
[Music]
it's the big day the bluebird team says
she's had to be teased cope stand cajole
back to life now she's leaving the North
Shields workshop where she has spent
years in recovery it's not every day you
see such a creature on your commute
[Music]
but it's not every day the local ferry
carries such an exotic passenger
[Music]
in her 1960s heyday Bluebird was the
envy of the world
[Music]
fired by an engine from a jet plane she
said seven world water speed records
a pilot Donald Campbell was just as
famous to an adoring public he was a
glamorous hero of the age on a par with
rock stars indestructible Donald
Campbell survivor of the most
spectacular crash in motoring history is
home again but this star was desperate
for another world record and then
another on a winter's day in the Lake
District in 1967 he pushed Bluebird too
far
[Music]
Donald Campbell died instantly nobody
then ever expected Bluebird to rise from
the depths of that Cumbrian lake for
such a fabled guest the arrival on Butte
has prompted a special welcome carrying
Donald Campbell's lucky mascot mr. WAP
it his daughter Gina sees the rebuilt
Bluebird for the first time she was 17
when her father died
the isle of bute with its population of
little over 7,000 was a controversial
choice for the relaunch
so the turnout has delighted the
bluebird team it's a special moment for
everyone involved but there's work to be
done
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the team wastes no time in getting her
to the edge of lock fat in readiness for
her return to the water
[Music]
she seems reluctant the listing that
everyone noticed back in North Hills is
happening again
[Music]
as the crane lowers Bluebird little by
little the hoist jams it's never
happened before
driver Duncan is puzzled as to how to
fix it
[Music]
after an anxious hour by the lakeside
the problem is solved Bluebird is put to
bed they often refer to the machine as
having a mind of her own certainly she
seems reluctant go back to the water
slide it okay
the next morning before Bluebird goes
anywhere
pilots Ted Walsh and Stu Campbell go
through a thorough safety briefing
hopefully I'll be with you within
seconds I will be following you as close
as I can all about and as soon as you
sink crash burn whatever you gonna do I
will be on top of your Lanka a rush
already an experienced hydroplane ace
and Stu a former red arrows pilot and no
strangers to danger but everyone is
mindful of bluebirds last outing on
water 51 years ago
if catastrophe were to strike again
diver Sally Cartwright would be
responsible for the rescue I have to
make sure these lads ain't gonna drop
well about half an hour before they all
start to really feel the hypothermic
effects the panic is what I'm worried
about as well which can bring on it's a
very big responsibility it's
nerve-racking
I'll be straight I'm nervous
as the water beckons bluebird displays
once again her apparent reluctance to go
back to the water to those who know the
hydroplane best this is typical of what
they call the camel curse there's one
thing I've learned on this project is
that as it says on the back of a lot of
our shirts it'll fix when she arrived at
here Khadija Coniston in 1966 she
immediately got stuck in the mud that's
what they call Campbell luck
poor old Donald always had bad luck it's
just history repeating itself after more
than half a century of silence from
bluebird nobody knows for sure how
she'll respond on water will she even
float
these are tense moments but then
[Applause]
[Music]
fantastic
how cool is that that's a lot of work
popping away no there may be better sell
hasn't signed yet
well you nervous no and you would float
for a while it's carried on flow I was
never nervous it was a bit of come on
come on come on come on you know that
when the kids were born come on I don't
want to see it spit like that looks like
somebody's making a movie about Campbell
and have left the prop lying in the play
this really looks like let's go on all
three 1966 out there now I'm a happy man
yeah well the thing is we've got to get
it back over the water and then that's
gonna be just as fraught so I'm a happy
man till we start the next operation
by their own admission Bill Smith and
Gina Campbell have had a nap times testy
relationship to you
only someone like you bloody-minded
difficult argumentative parsing
difficult disagreeable disagree
yes from you jealousy was it you ugly
[Music]
onlookers are clearly mesmerised by the
sight of this historic machine taking
once more to the water it's a fine sight
too for those who were there when she
was discovered 40 meters down the bed of
Coniston water question are you gonna
rebuild it what excuse me I did not put
the engine in and if you put the engine
in what's your excuse for not connecting
at all and if you connect at all what's
your excuse for not starting and that's
just a natural progression so as soon as
the idea was out there let's rebuild it
then this was the inevitable conclusion
Lock fad was chosen because of its long
straight stretch of water the next step
is to get Bluebird moving again at speed
[Music]
under study pilots through Campbell a
relation to Donald tests out the engine
Bluebird continues her relaunch trials
on the isle of bute in stopping
it's a sound that nobody has heard since
the January day of 1967 when Bluebird
crashed a sound that was silenced as she
lay on the bed of Coniston water for 34
years waiting for that day when she
would rise again
now it's time for her first proper run
since then she's pilot and Walsh takes
over that is alone with his thoughts
history shows that it's got a certain
edge to it and if you push it too far
it'll bite you in the bomb fatality is
not the norm in powerboat racing as it
is in any motor sport but it is is a
feature of it it's a new craft and a new
new way of driving it so we those are
new things are always things to bear in
mind an approach with caution more than
anything else
[Music]
in her initial lower speed runs Bluebird
performs better than the team dared to
expect as jubilation all round
[Music]
once it smoothed out and spray died away
and pushed a load more throttle in and
it was you know we were pretty much
close to planing at that point so yeah
[Music]
what did you think Gina Oh magic magic
did we ever think this day would happen
it's an emotional moment to for the team
of volunteers who spent so long
rebuilding Bluebird absolutely just on
it
we've all done pass on it we've well
worked on it and to see back on the
water especially under its own power it
was absolutely brilliant it seems to me
you're always traveling back in time
because you're seeing what people saw
back then we got to see that so this is
you know the greatest part of it I
wasn't alive I was -13 at that point I
was even in the planning stage not to
see it
for real is you know really really
special in the workshops he's brought us
every inch of the way and when we got
her back here and decided to take her
out onto the onto the lock for the first
time it was the so she was she was
saying I don't want to go I don't want
to go I remember what happened the last
time don't make me do it but we took her
for stirred and maybe a little gently
the Sun came out
the lock sparkled and she just did some
gentle pirouettes and and said to us all
look at me I'm back
[Music]
bill Smith's family have lived and
breathed Bluebird please let it float
please let it float because that you
think of all the work that's gone in it
and think please and then today when
they start the engine thinking please
let this go right and then when they
took it out was thinking please just
please let it work and when it started
to move us like it's moving and from
team leader Bill Smith another
enthusiastic response now I'm excited
and now I'm excited that was it just
works how did that happen
ten years of building something that
works an abundance but the next run at
speed reminds everyone that although
Bluebird has a certain majesty there's
also an ever-present danger
as a speed of over a hundred and fifty
miles an hour
bluebirds canopy is torn off flying 100
feet into the air pilots response is
characteristically phlegmatic when we
stopped off at the appropriate point
then they all all hell broke loose it
just upsets you as a driver when
something sudden like that happens you
have to try and assimilate the situation
basically only Donald Campbell would
have known exactly what Ted Walsh was
feeling now the changing times had put
Campbell under even greater stress
[Music]
seismic events were shaping a new world
as Donald Campbell was preparing for
what would be his final record-breaking
run but pressure was building up for the
Spree days he had been the toast of 1950
society that seemed out of step with the
less reverential spirit of the 60s
it took off again and that I think three
more times before finally coming down
sideways Arden
he'd been thinking about quitting but he
couldn't and then there was his
superstition he had all sorts of way
things and traditions and things never
wish him good luck because that was bad
luck and you know don't all the obvious
things he had a thing about the color
green he believed in the supernatural he
believed in his father's presence
Gina feels that on more than one
occasion
her father spirit is present as the
reborn Bluebird prepares for her last
high-speed runs on what five
for those who witnessed Donald
Campbell's crash old memories are
stirred we walked over and it would take
is a good hour hour and after what to
walk across the woods and then we sat we
just got a clearing and sat there and
and watched and waited it was a speed I
think we wanted to see flying and
virtually flying and he did did sloppy
it did get a move on and that's that was
the excitement we just knew there's an
accident never thought of anybody been
killed or anything he just he just just
flipped over and you just mostly
yourself splashes and and then he just
disappeared
also paying homage of spectators whose
presence reflects Bluebirds
international appeal living in Melbourne
at the moment and I've come to see this
well I remember the original event so
it's not Aldi I suppose as much as
anything but it was spectacular to see
it run for the first time
it's the last day of Bluebirds
high speed runs the smashed canopy
replaced she is back to her best
of the lock there seems an ever-present
spirit of the life the bluebird left
behind
they insist that she is far more than
just a machine
sometimes you can't dispel the feeling
that a machine has some sort of so some
sort of I don't know it's indefinable
but you know you work with that boat for
long enough and she comes across I was
thoughts arose as she as being a
malevolent bad-tempered old witch of a
thing you know and you just can't shake
that just that's how it feels a lot of
the time she just plain doesn't like you
I suppose I went through a stage when I
hated her she taken my dad away but now
seeing her reborn oh I can't take my
eyes off her she's she is it magnetism
that she's got and I don't think it's
just me that feels it I've seen
thousands this week just sit there
groaning crying with emotion and how can
a machine do that it's just you know I'm
starting to sort of fill up thinking
about it she's beautiful
Bluebird is about face one last big test
the double run of the lake and back
on her return there's tension in the air
as she comes closer to the shoreline and
suddenly shifts closer still
was this meant to happen releases some
nervous energy I thought I'm going going
this curve on me can we ask for no
profanity at the safety debrief there's
an altogether more serious atmosphere we
haven't worked our lives project leader
puts it down to a stressful week the
team everybody from launch to recovery
that maintenance they're putting the
tent up with taking it down that blowing
air and fetching and carrying fuel a
whole lot to be absolutely outstanding
and fantastic and it's my privilege to
work with everybody yeah so I think the
time has come that was you're right we
stop no more fast runs proved the point
we're on a high the last one was
exciting to say the least
no harm done let's walk away we can do
some slow speed taxis a bit of floating
for the cameras maybe just starting
engine run but what we need now is a
bigger league let's walk the way on a
high
[Music]
there's still talk of bluebird going
back one day to what people call her
spiritual home the lake in Coniston when
tragedy struck yes people say she should
go to Coniston but Coniston simply has
nothing in place to facilitate this
despite a decade to get it ready and
that is that's tragic it shouldn't have
happened that way now for the legend by
common consent she's certainly not ready
for the museum just yet her appeal as a
piece of British history is beyond
question
she has risen from the dark the wreckage
she became back to the spirit she was
born to be
you